so men are outraged by this video there
is a video of a woman that got breast
reduction surgery going viral let's pull
it
[Music]
UPS in my head and they won't go Spirits
in my head and they won't go I gots in
my head and they won't go Spirits in my
head and they won't go I got GS in my
head and they won't go Spirits in my
head and they won't go I got in my head
and they won't go Spirits in my head and
they won't go I gots in my head and they
Spirits in my head and they won't
go so men have seen this video and are
outraged let's let's read the
comments do women consider ever just
wearing a bra now I've seen this go
viral because the men you know guys
because men really don't like it when
you get a lot of work done it's just not
their thing um I've heard men compare
this to you know reduction surgery like
to a guy I don't want to say it but you
guys get that his shadow says I try to
get my girl to take off her bra and hers
are pretty big sadly she loves the bra
so much just looking at this point she
has two indents in her shoulders just
looking at the indents from the bra
strap it looks painful so Ron says she
went from being overwhelmingly popular
to average yeah guys
men you know there's a lot of debate
because you know I guess women have back
issues when they have like big boobs but
you know the men are really outraged
about this so speaking of crazy um you
guys know I've been covering the story
of Joe Smith a former NBA Legend and his
wife facing difficulties in their
marriage due to his wife wife starting
an only fans funny thing is when I
covered this video last time the woman
basically saying that money was worth
the only fans and he didn't notice for a
year do you know what the comments were
in the video oh he didn't pay attention
to her oh what she had to start the only
fans because he wasn't paying attention
to her are you guys kidding
me maybe he was busy
working maybe had other stuff going on
I'm sorry one year of not getting
attention is not worth only fans what
crazy people are you um anyways so I
wanted to point out why women like this
are delusional for a lifetime uh they
signal easy sex to other men and
oftentimes they get a lot of takers even
though they're absolute degenerate so
let's pull up the
video what else have you been doing
besides only fans and what have y'all
been going through financially that you
felt you had to do this I've had a
bartending service called chill
arrow with kiss since I've been here I
have um a moving company called major
movers and cleaning and then I also have
a massage business called the body rub
babes nice are the do the body rub babes
travel yes they do are you one of the
body rub
babes well I have been but now I kind of
like
kind but if I wanted you to be one of my
body rub babes like uh would you be a
body rub babe for me
oh yeah sure okay cause I don't mean to
be a professional or anything like that
but I can't stop looking at your
cleavage it's it's you got y your
cleavage is popping babe now you can
leave it it was man you can leave it
exactly how it was man I right now I'm
thinking about
cleavage yeah so this guy shoots his
shot at this woman mid interview and
this is how these women go through life
in delusion obviously that's that's a
sexual ask that man is not going to wife
this o chick and porn star and so the
women go through life thinking they have
a higher sexual market value than they
do when really she's just an average
chick with big boobs she's I mean even
worse than that she's really a a
prostitute with some big
boobs and really she's never going to be
taken seriously she got lucky that she
got an NBA player to take her seriously
the first time um and but women keep
getting bailed out of their bad
decisions so let's see the rest of the
video cleavage and the body rub B
but don't cover schol it's it's like you
know um yeah
baby um sorry to get off track man but
um sorry about that kiss we'll talk
afterwards but um about the body R bab
and everything else but um you just
threw me off for a minute if it's not me
it' be someone equally as beautiful
I mean yeah I see why Joe was a little
upset you are very very pretty and from
at least the stomach up there sexy and
gorgeous to say to say the
[Music]
least and look she's she's a beautiful
woman she's a pretty woman but the issue
is she's really depleted her sexual
market value um she's just going to be
for fun now really she had a good thing
where she had it she's going to think
that the grass is greener on the other
side and for most Wom
it is not most single mothers do not
remarry the majority do not remarry I I
want to stress this to you guys the
majority of single mothers do not have
Happy Endings only 22% get a guy to live
with them only around 15% get a guy to
marry them most do not remarry and
selling dreams sells them a happy ending
that they will not have so let's take a
look at the
comments if your wife putting herself
out there there
like um so let's look at the comments if
your wife is putting herself out there
like that it's fair game go to the next
one the fact that she says sure to being
his body rub girl and she didn't cover
up after his comments says that she is
for the streets
obviously um Batman says he's actually
helping the husband out showing that she
ain't yeah and you know this is
women's nature they just tend to move on
to the next best thing they crave for
the excitement and once a woman has had
a certain lifestyle and a certain level
of excitement it is tough to go come
back from that so A couple of months ago
I covered alpacino having a kid with a
28-year-old woman so that's alpacino
that is his girlfriend they break up and
now he's being ordered to pay $30,000 a
month in child support this man is in
his 70s and
now it has to pay astronomical fees for
a child what on Earth do you need 30k a
month for for one kid is this money
really just going to be spent on the
children I think that any child I think
child support should be banned but if we
are going to keep having child support
it should be put in a fund that is only
used for the kid that only the kid gets
it not the mother the comments on this
say 82 with a baby she ain't got many
payments um to grow up and find out you
were just a pawn in your mama's get rich
scheme
I still don't know what kid needs
$30,000 a month to live I'm 25 taking
care of myself and I pay real bills and
they damn sure don't cost that yeah what
why do kids have to have the same level
of Lifestyle with their dad and with
their mom there's some idea that if the
Mom leaves she's somehow entitled to
bring her child up in a environment that
is the same luxury as the dad I say
don't leave your baby father if you
can't pay for it women should not be
rewarded for leaving and breaking up
homes now this child is growing up in a
situation where you know how old is
alucino going to live He's 82 and now
he's being raised with a mother that is
a very clear gold dier